cuando los chicos escuchan que eres vi
siempre si quieres ver un
unicornio
jubilee reunimos a siete bisexuales
yo soy bisexual soy bisexual soy
bisexual soy bisexual soy bisexual soy
bisexual
yo soy bisexual
uno es un mentiroso si el grupo descubre
quiénes se repartirán un premio en
efectivo
si el mentiroso sobrevive ganará todo el
premio
quién es el impostor civil y onenote
bisexuales
marisa soy si de él y melvin moli estaba
nervioso porque todos estaban buscando
cómo podría encajar una persona bisexual
cómo definirías la bisexualidad en tus
propias palabras para mí es sentirse
atraído por los seres humanos donde veo
a las personas por su corazón y su alma
y también me importa el exterior
desconfiaba de david porque era quien me
hacía sentir que no era bisexual david
tiene un aspecto macetero en comparación
con los demás he salido tanto con chicas
y chicos eso no significa que eres bi o
no y lo veo como una fluidez
a veces me gustan más los hombres más
las mujeres pero da igual no es una fase
pasajera siempre voy a ser bisexual no
importa con quién salga para mí es lo
mismo básicamente yo no tengo ninguna
preferencia hace poco bien dictó que
alguien bisexual podías sentir atracción
por personas no binarias y de género
linar yo me dije me gusta más eso porque
siento que es más inclusivo sentí que
moli era muy de sí misma y eso me
pareció sospechoso está cerca del pan
sexual es casi lo mismo porque no se
siente
bien muy bien fotos de los seguidores
quienes el impostor
mi instinto me decía que él y podría ser
la intrusa
sentía que debía votar por molly porque
era una apuesta segura
[Música]
tenemos un empate entre el
y molly
eso significa que vamos a un desempate
lo que vamos a hacer es darles 20
segundos a cada uno para exponer su caso
bien no sé qué decirles tal vez soy muy
fuerte pero tengo una gran personalidad
soy bisexual lo he cuestionado muchas
veces antes pero al fin me identifique y
sé lo que siento y espero que puedan
verlo muy bien yo sabía que era bi o no
heterosexual o lesbiana desde que tenía
unos 8 años cuando mis padres me vieron
buscando chicas besándose en youtube
angélica de rugrats fue lo que inició
esto para mí así que soy muy gay
[Risas]
creo que las respuestas de molly cuando
estaba tratando de probarse a sí misma
eran demasiado acertadas definitivamente
muy estereotipadas
mis radares están apagados
si no me equivoco cuestiono mi juicio
[Música]
me conozco sabía cómo presentarme porque
soy yo y soy bisexual pero creo que es
ser yo misma zona va demasiado ensayado
qué tipo de música escuchen qué artistas
les gusta selena gomez
y
miley
cyrus
favoritas
mi apellido en internet
francois yo ni música francesa yo desde
el principio sospeche de melvin el
impostor podría ser también alguien que
es como un nombre femenino tengo una
pregunta cuando salieron todos y cómo
fue la reacción de la familia y de los
amigos cuando se lo dije a mis padres
pensé no puedo fue muy difícil estábamos
hablando y le dije mamá tengo que
decirte algo y ella que y le dije me
gustan las chicas y los chicos y ella
dijo bien nadie lo esperaba pero todos
lo aceptaron siento que porque a veces
estoy más con chicos la gente me
cuestiona dice o eres bisexual o no yo
me lo cuestioné varias veces el segundo
o tercer año de la universidad me sentí
que podía identificarme con la
bisexualidad real y cuando me gradué de
la secundaria era femenino con mi forma
de caminar de hablar y todo y yo pensaba
que era gay luego me encontré con una
chica y dije soy gay en realidad me
gustan los dos supongo que soy bea' salí
como lesbiana en octavo grado y luego el
noveno me di cuenta de que me gustaba un
chico suele salir más con chicos ahora
sí pero antes salía más con chicas y
luego con los chicos pero salgo con
ambos sí sí
ella sabía lo que decía pero no había
una conexión emocional tan fuerte en su
cara sonaba como alguien que había
investigado sobre la bisexualidad cuáles
son los estereotipos tontos que han
escuchado y que son realmente molestos
para sacaríamos y si no nos
comprometemos a mí es como eres vi para
salir con todos de sus parejas ha dicho
más competencia
es como que no estoy contigo exacto
aunque una vez salí con un chico y una
chica al mismo tiempo no salió vigente
pero por una vez sentí que la gente me
validaba
antes estabas actuando yo estaba como
así ahora que soy gay o no porque me
gustan las cosas así creo que también es
saber cuándo porque cuando los chicos
escuchan que eres vis siempre es como
quieres hacerlo
no soy un unicornio debería lo primero
que siempre le dicen a las mujeres es
has estado con una chica y a los hombres
siempre les dicen no eres bisexual eres
gay cuando me preguntan te gustan más
las chicas y los chicos no quiero
responder porque siempre cambia como has
dicho solo he salido con chicos pero
todavía me atraen las mujeres
pero piensas que eres para hacerte la
vida más fácil
para los chicos en ese sentido las
chicas es como no
quieres experimentar
por dios
vote por sí ni porque no se parecía un
poco nerviosa
de verdad no lo sé yo sospechaba un poco
de él y porque sentí que los chicos
estaban como en equipo quería votar por
ella para no ser expulsada
lo siento lo siento la verdad no lo sé
está bien espero que encuentren al
hetero chicos aunque estaba confundida
porque me eligieron a mí tal vez yo
estaba hablando demasiado no sé todo el
mundo estaba muy callado sentí que tenía
que hablar si quieren seguir jugando por
favor levantan la mano en
tengo una pregunta y fue difícil para
ustedes salir del closet porque fue muy
difícil para mí porque nunca me enamoré
de un chico solo me enamoraba de chicas
recuerdo que fue justo después de
graduarme en la secundaria estaba
investigando sobre la sexualidad del
espectro y todo existe el test sí sí
muchos
eso incluso ahora sigo teniendo momentos
en los que me pregunto que soy pero me
siento seguro diciendo que soy bea' y
creo que fue difícil para mí como dije
antes fue más para mí que para mi
familia y la gente que me rodea pero fue
un reto descubrirlo lo siento pero dudo
de ti
como vote por si ni dos veces y tuve que
decirle en medio del juego melvin me
señaló como sospechosa ahora todos van a
votar por mi un dios mío no sé qué
preguntar tú sólo tienen un personaje de
la televisión que los represente como
beef y me llama análisis del world yo
estaba en un episodio de di el world
como una persona de fondo del frente
comenzó la primera 16 en mi secundaria
no sé qué más ya realmente quiere el
dinero
ella trató de defenderse pero no fue
convincente para mí no quiero preguntar
pero cuando es el mes del orgullo que
junio
nunca me gustó
lo siento de verdad tengo dudas sobre ti
pero siento que en este programa piensan
en los estereotipos siento que soy muy
femenina así que sería muy fácil para mí
ser heterosexual eso es justo es justo
si sospechaba de sydney pero luego hubo
un momento en que también sospechaba de
melvin el hecho de que fuera en contra
de sydney me hizo pensar un poco en eso
chicos estoy diciendo la verdad no sé
esto es difícil de verdad dios mío dios
mío esto es difícil
en la tercera ronda empecé tal vez a
dudar un poco de mí mismo pensando bien
podría hacer cine
este es es mi foto voy a hacer yo o
marisa pensé que los chicos votarían
contra las chicas porque dos chicas
fueron expulsadas en las dos primeras
rondas
lo lamento arruinaron estaba triste
porque me agradaban todos confiaba en
todos así que lo arruinaron pero también
me lo esperaba si se sienten seguros de
que sacaron al impostor pueden terminar
el juego aquí por favor levanten la mano
si quieren continuar el juego en 3 2 1
eres tú
porque no quiero pensar que estoy seguro
de ti el 90% está seguro de mí bien me
conformo con eso creo que tiene una
buena intuición no eso parece si la luz
se pone en verde significa que
expulsaron al impostor y caen el espero
que ganemos sí sí sí la luz se pone en
rojo el impostor sigue y pierden
estaba nerviosa desde el principio
porque pensé que sería expulsada primero
así que me alegré mucho cuando llegué al
final siento que estoy en el lugar
correcto es donde quería estar podría el
impostor dar un paso adelante y
revelarse en
3-2-1
no soy bisexual soy heterosexual creo
que mucha gente tuvo dificultades para
averiguar quién era bisexual no tenía
una táctica realmente no se puede saber
quién es bisexual basándose en una
salida me gusta no
lo sé porque tenía que despistar los ser
bisexual es simplemente amar a quien
quieres amar es sentirse atraído por el
hombre la mujer y puede ir un poco más
allá más puertas abiertas así veo la
bisexualidad tenemos el dinero o no dios
mío no lanzaré
aunque llueva dinero
difícil
[Música]